hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
one of the best ways to create financial
freedom through property starting with
very little money is rent to rent now
maybe you don't know what rent to rent
is in which case i would suggest you
watch this video that flashes right up
on the card and i'll also leave it in
the description and you can learn what a
rent to rent is if you know what our
internet is but you're just struggling
to get one this is the video for you i'm
going to give you the best 10 ways to
find a rent to rent deal and to find it
fast i'm not just going to tell you what
to do i'm going to show you live right
now you're going to see my laptop screen
and i'm going to find leads and show you
the best 10 ways to do it if you like my
videos hit like you're going to enjoy
this one so the first way to find rent
to rent leads is is you can go to a
special website called open rent
now open rent is the equivalent to right
move but it's landlords direct so let's
say you're looking for a rent to rent in
i don't know
manchester
just search
and then boom shakalaka straight away
studio flats studio flats these are all
opportunities to be turned into serviced
apartments and the great thing about
these types of properties is you click
on them and you can literally message
the landlord
direct here we go his name is call deep
so that is one way open rent a second
way to find rent to rent leads is you
can let's say you're trying to get a
rent to hmo and you're looking for tired
landlords that might have hmos you can
literally let's type in
birmingham
let's say i'm based in birmingham
birmingham hmo
license
list
look at this public register of hmo
licenses
you can go on the council website
press download
and this will give me right here this is
absolutely shocking
you can get a list bang
this is a list starting with 40 hamster
road it's still opening but right now we
can see every
single hmo in the entire of birmingham
here we go personal road i've got houses
in personal roads you're about to find
some of mine
you can see how many bedrooms
everything's here
all the way down you can literally just
write a letter to these landlords and
say hey what's up
if you're interested in renting out your
property and getting a guaranteed rent
or if you want to sell give me a shout
too many to even go through absolutely
crazy next
you can go to a website called spare
room
and again if i type in let's do
coventry
and i'm looking for rooms
bang
so all these these are existing hmos
you're going to find the ones generally
speaking that are a little bit tired
maybe not the boosted ones the ones that
aren't advertised very well the ones
that look a little bit tired the ones
that aren't renting out and if you click
on these
now let's try this one because this
isn't furnished very well let's face it
it doesn't look great it looks like a 17
year old bedroom look
landlord
bang call you can get their number
immediately and say hey
if you want to rent out the whole house
to me i potentially could be interested
in the rent to rent boom
next we're gonna go to another website
called gumtree
country.com
i want to find landlords on gumtree
let's try uh properties for rent
and let's do somewhere completely
different let's try york
bang
950 for a two bed flat that could be a
serviced accommodation property
one bed flat all bills included
these properties and again the great
thing about these is that you can rent
them
you've got the number of the um of how
to speak to the agent direct
they're all different
don't spend too much time doing due
diligence on the properties just call
them and see if they're potentially open
there's ron bang ron could this be a
nice little holiday let maybe let's
speak to ron so gumtree is an absolutely
incredible way one bed flat in york
there's his number boom shakalaka
there's his number
and
here's the property let's see
whereabouts it is there should be a map
on gumtree yes there is
bang
right in the center of york so here's a
property a one bud flat for a thousand
pounds a month you could probably rent
that out for a hundred hundred and
twenty pounds a night make a nice little
profit especially if you can negotiate
the price lower because you're offering
a corporate let
there's a rent to an opportunity uh next
there's just so many there's ten next is
if you go to facebook bang facebook now
listen you might not you might think
this idea is a bit whack but you can
just type in a facebook post and to tell
your friends and family if there's so
many people that are probably connected
to you that are in property might be
landlords you don't even know the
average person's got 2 000 friends on
facebook you just say i am looking
to rent
a house
on a
corporate lap
any landlords
here
bang i'm sure i'll get a lead off that
maybe even a deal i'll let you know
another thing you can do is you can go
to the facebook marketplace marketplace
here and you can look straight away um
we'll type in an area let's type in
um
we've got doncaster at the moment let's
do leads
if i'm looking for somewhere in leads
apply
i'm looking for houses and leads
so i'm going to search
properties
for rent
on facebook marketplace would you look
at that two bedroom
four bedroom
these are all properties two bedroom
apartment that could be a service
department rent to rent right there and
we can message the seller
shaka
maybe i should maybe not maybe i'll
leave it till later i'll do that later
because right now i'm trying to give you
the 10 ways how to find rent to rent not
how to secure a rent to rent first
you've got to be able to find loads and
loads of those leads next i can go to
rightmove
let's say i'm looking for rental rents
in
kent
looking for some rent to hmos in kent
okay so i'm gonna do for rent
and i'm gonna search this area only
houses in kent number of bedrooms
minimum of five
and let's see what we've got
so these are all big five bed houses
these could be perfect hmos this could
be a perfect hmo right here
let me look at there's no floor plan but
there's five bedrooms you could you
could rent that off of the landlord for
1700 and then rent each room out for
probably five six hundred pounds a month
make a nice profit of course you need to
check the rules and regulation in the
area you need to get permission from the
landlord but bang right move great way
to find leads next let's say your area
is london
if you're looking for rent to rent in
london you can just put london
letting
agents london letting agents
and literally just phone these agents
there's absolutely
hundreds look acorn
so many
ring them up and just look pages and
pages and pages sometimes i like to go
to the like the eighth page and find the
agents they're a little bit smaller not
such big agents so these guys have only
got like 18 reviews
okay so some of these smaller agencies
supernova um noah's london maybe you'll
ring up and you'll actually speak to
noah i'm not sure but you're going to
ring these small agents and tell them
what you're doing tell them your
company's looking to rent company let's
how it works bang agents another thing
you can do next way is
walk into agents just go to a town
center and just walk in we call these
walk-ins walk into the agent letting
agents go in person dress nicely build
rapport tell them your story next way to
get rent to rent and then the final way
number 10 is networking events go places
where landlords are and tell people what
you're wanting to do rehearse a 30
second elevator pitch get around get out
the house so those are the top 10 ways
to find rent to rent i hope you found
this video useful also
maybe now your problem isn't finding
rent to rent leads maybe now you know
how to find rent to rent leads but you
need to know what to say and how to
secure them and how to carry out your
due diligence and how to make sure it's
legal so guess what i'm going to be
running a one-day training program
teaching all things rent to rent it's
called the rent to rent revolution and
i'm desperate to see you become
financially free through rent to rent so
that then you can come on my youtube
channel and i can interview you on
winners on a wednesday and be part of
your success story so i've got tickets
below and guess what tickets right now
are completely free they are limited so
get booked on right now to the rent to
rent revolution i'm going to be touring
all across the country so find the
location that's closest to your house
get booked on i'll see you there let's
get some rent to rent together this year
again if you don't know what rent to
rent is check in the description i've
done a whole video on what rent to rents
are and if you want to see stories of
hundreds of people that have become
financially free through my training
which is free check out this video
playlist right here get booked onto the
rent to rent revolution i can't wait to
see you win let's do it man
hey
[Music]